after growing this
I don't think I'm ever gonna look at
mushrooms the same way again
this is Maia Mycelium, my pet pink oyster mushroom
and she's giving birth for the second time this season
and unbeknownst to her I will eat her tasty babies
but that macabre story’s for another day
because for today all we need to know is that
fungi are fkn fascinating
her full fruiting process only took five days
cause apparently mushrooms favour
cell expansion over cell division
so essentially they're just inflating cells that they already have
which is wild
I also don't know how to feel about the fact
that some mushrooms can solve puzzles
and I'm sure I don't need to remind you
that they don't have a brain
apparently they have a long and complicated history with humanity
and may have even played a role in our consciousness
and of course we can't forget that
more than 600 types can turn their
host into a literal zombie
food for thought I guess